[Music]
Well, hello good uh good friends of
Secrets Unsealed and Some TV. We're glad
that you decided to join us today for
our question and answer program. I'd
like to know. Uh for those who are
tuning in for the first time to this
program, uh I just want to mention that
this is a question and answer program
where you send us your questions, we do
the research, and then we answer the
questions on television and social
media. So please send us your questions.
Let me give you the electronic address.
It's tvsumtv.org.
Once again, tvsumtv.org.
We'd be delighted to get your questions.
We don't answer them live because uh
many of the questions require serious
research before we provide an answer. I
have with me the general manager of SMTV
Latino and uh we're very very glad to
have you here working in this program.
>> Thank you, Pastor Bor. It's always an
honor to work with you and to uh be able
to be mentored by your experience and
your knowledge. So, it's a blessing to
be for for me to be with you.
>> Well, praise the Lord.
>> Amen. For that. Uh we want to begin as
we always do with a word of prayer.
>> Uh never should we open God's word
without prayer is the way that Ellen
White expresses it.
>> So would you please pray for us?
>> Absolutely. Let us pray.
Gracious heavenly father, as we come
before you, we thank you first of all
for giving us the desire to uh study the
scriptures. And I thank you for those
who are watching who want to know more
about what you have said and how they
can receive an answer to their
questions, receive guidance to their
lives. And so I pray that you will use
us now. Help us to receive the Holy
Spirit in our minds, in our hearts, so
that what we may share, what we may
respond may be according to your will.
And may you be glorified is our prayer.
I pray this in Jesus name. Amen.
Well, Pastor Salasar, what question do
we have on the docket first today?
>> Pastor Bor, we have a very good
question. Uh, as usual, we have good
questions. This question comes from
Michael from Mississippi and, uh, he
actually has two questions, and I'm
going to read both of them, and then
we'll answer those two questions he has.
He says, first, um, uh, love I love how
God uses you to teach the his word. So
my question is if Revelation 11 talks
about a beast and we know that that was
France atheist, how is it not one of the
seven heads since it is a beast? And my
second question is uh Rome has kingdom
by it was a kingdom by itself then
divided to 10 kingdoms and then little
horn the papacy.
So since little horn is a head will not
the second stage be one of the heads see
it has since it has 10 horns. We know
Rome is the fourth and we said the
papacy is the fifth but why wouldn't a
head be out of the 10 before little horn
time 476 to 538. I know they grow from
the head of the Rome, the fourth uh
beast, but the papacy did not I mean but
the papacy did too and is counted as a
head. So wouldn't time from 476 to 538
be ahead too. Thank you and God bless.
I've been studying Daniel Revelation
last three years and have uh and like
many times out of the week I studied 8
to 12 hours. I'm telling you this
because God has to be working me. No way
I could do without his will. I hope you
uh me and you, Pastor Bo, can talk more
one day. I see your passion in it and
studying prophecy hands down is my
favorite thing to me now. Thank you and
sorry for the long text. So this is
Michael writing from uh Mississippi with
two questions. First one, Revelation 11
mentions a beast. Why is not that beast
uh one of the seven heads? Uh and then
speaking of the seven head beast in
revelation 13 he is basically saying
that there is four heads the fourth
being Rome then the fifth head that is
the papal papacy should instead be that
time period between the fall if you
could say of the Roman Empire to the
raise of the papal power. So please
explain to us you know what this really
means. Well, let me address the first
question. It has to do with the beast of
Revelation 11, uh, which we believe
represents France, uh, who gave the
deadly wound to the papacy at the end of
the 1260 years,
>> right?
>> Um, very clearly, uh, that is not one of
the heads of that dragon beast that has
seven heads uh, for for two reasons
primarily. First of all, it is not a
world kingdom.
All of the seven heads are world
kingdoms that ruled in succession.
Babylon, Meo, Persia, Greece, the Roman
Empire, the papacy, and then the United
States, which is a global power, and
finally uh the the United States joined
with the papacy at the end of time, the
papacy revived. Uh so very very clearly
uh the beast of revelation 11 uh deals
with a specific nation that did not
become in global in influence. Um also
um all of the uh seven heads of the
dragon beast are persecuting kingdoms.
>> You know Babylon they threw three young
men into the fiery furnace and Daniel uh
then Meo Persia threw Daniel into the
lion's den. Yeah,
>> Greece was a persecuting power.
>> Rome was a terrible persecuting power.
The papacy was as well.
>> And uh you know during the during the
transitional period of the 10 kingdoms,
there's no evidence that God's people
were specifically persecuted
>> and then the United States will become a
persecuting power and the papacy at the
end of time will become a persecuting
power again. Uh in Revelation 11, uh
France destroys the persecutor.
>> That's right. That's right. So it's not
persecuting God's people. It's actually
persecuting the power that trampled on
God's people during the 1260 years. Uh
so for those reasons, uh the the beast
of Revelation 11, uh is not included in
the sequence of seven kingdoms. Um I
might read a statement by JN Andrews,
>> uh a pioneer of the Adventist Church,
the first missionary to Switzerland,
first missionary, uh of the 7th
Adventist Church. went to Switzerland um
where he comments on uh these last three
beasts.
>> Mhm.
>> And uh it's a very powerful statement.
You know, JN Andrews was a fabulous uh
scholar.
>> He was a biblical scholar. In fact,
Ellen White wrote to him and tell told
him, "Don't study so much because it's
hurting your eyes."
>> So, um but he was an intense researcher
and did a lot of good things for the
Adventist church. This is what he wrote
about uh the last three heads of uh this
dragon beast.
>> He wrote the seven heads are seven forms
of civil power
>> which successively bear rule.
These seven heads belong alike to the
dragon of Revelation 12, the beast of
chapter 13 and that of Revelation 17. In
other words, there's a link between
Revelation 12, 13, and 17. But he
continues writing, "This shows
conclusively that the dragon and these
two beasts are symbols of the same power
under different heads.
>> They symbolize the same power, the same
uh nation if you please um but on
different heads, the last three heads."
Then he writes, "For there are not three
sets of seven heads, but it is evidence
that the heads are successive forms of
its power, one of them bearing rule at a
time."
>> Mhm.
>> And then giving place to another. The
proper period of each seems to be this.
Now he's going to interpret the dragon
that tried to slay the male child
before the 1260 years. the beast of
chapter 13 that's the
>> papacy
>> during that period during the 1260 years
and the beast of chapter 17 since the
deadly wound and captivity at the close
of that period.
>> So what he's saying is that the last
three heads represent pagan Rome, papal
Rome, and resurrected Rome at the end of
time when his deadly wound is healed. um
all of those are persecuting powers.
>> Mhm.
>> And so um I believe that his
interpretation is absolutely correct.
And of course uh France is not included
there. The beast of revelation 11 is not
included there. And uh if somebody wants
the source of this it's JN Andrews the
three messages of Revelation 14 6-12
pages 77 and 78. Uh so so for those
reasons uh the beast that rises from the
abyss uh is not one of the heads because
uh because of the reasons that I
mentioned. Now regarding the second uh
question regarding uh why the 10
kingdoms between 476 and 538 do not
count as one of the heads is because
clearly in in these prophecies this is a
transitional period. M
>> there is really no ruling kingdom. Rome
continues to exist but in a divided
state but uh the barbarians put the
whole kingdom into disarray. There was
no centralized government
>> and these kingdoms did not persecute
God's people. So the 10 horns are to be
uh considered a transitional period
between pagan Rome and papal Rome. It's
a period of disarray in between where
eventually because the kingdom has
fallen into disarray. Then it's
necessary in their minds to get a
centralized ruler who can be bring peace
and uh and prosperity back. And that's
where the bishop of Rome steps to the
plate and becomes a kingdom. So in other
words, that's the reason why the T horns
uh are not included in the heads because
the T horns are not a big worldwide
kingdom right now.
>> Right?
>> So for those reasons uh we consider that
the 10 horns are a transitional period
between pagan Rome and paple Rome.
>> Amen pastor. Wow. Thank you. uh I think
that helps um to really solve the
question and we have I mean you have
extensive research in this particular
topic. I know you have a you know
several study guides that perhaps our
friends could could actually get and and
to be able to study. I know you have a
one in Revelation 12, Revelation 13. You
have one about uh Revelation 17 and all
that. So I think that we have a lot of
material that uh we invite Michael and
those who are watching to to be able to
to order or to download in their in
their devices from our website.
>> In fact, the latest study notes that I
did
>> are showing that Daniel 2 is expanded in
Daniel 7.
>> Daniel 2 and 7 are expanded in
Revelation 12.
>> Daniel 2:7 and Revelation 12 are
expanded in chapter 13.
>> Yes. and Daniel 2:7, Revelation 12 and
13 are expanded finally in Revelation
17.
>> Uh so so you know that clearly will
answer this question further and that is
uh we're dealing with worldwide
kingdoms.
>> Yes.
>> That persecute God's people.
>> Amen. So look into our website for uh
this latest anchor series that we had
this year. uh we encourage you to order
that material is very important very
valuable resource to understand these
parts of the Bible. Uh okay so we have
another question pastor and um this is a
good question as well comes from Jerome
from Maryland and the question it says
is this one. I have read and always
assume that Satan will come pretending
to be Christ before probation is closed
as Satan's last crowning act.
Although recently I have heard that
Satan will come after probation is
closed after the sealing of the saints.
Can you please explain which is true and
where I can find more information of the
timeline of this event in the Bible and
LG white books? Thanks. So this is a
good question pastor. you know uh he
believed that Satan's personification of
Jesus would come right before the cause
of provision as the last desperate act
to deceive the world. That's how he he
had believed but some you know lately he
has heard from other speakers perhaps
that that might not be true. So pastor
which one is true which one is the right
understanding of this particular uh act
of Satan to deceive the world by
personification personificating Christ?
Well, there are several things that we
need to say
>> about uh either before or after. I
personally believe that it's after uh
the close of probation that Satan is
going to uh try to personate Jesus
Christ.
>> And um you know that goes against what
uh the white estate has established uh
in the book last day events. Uh it's
placed long before the close of
probation. And the theory is that uh the
purpose of the personation of Christ is
to deceive the world into adopting a
Sunday law.
>> In other words, the focus is on the
world. In other words, this in other
words, the in order to convince people
that they should em embrace the Sunday
law, Satan is going to personate Christ
and tell them that he wants them to
embrace a Sunday law. Uh but uh you know
we need to be careful about things that
appear to be reasonable but are not in
harmony with scripture.
>> For for this brother Jerome I would
recommend that you get the study notes.
Behold I send you Elijah.
>> Uh these are available from Secrets
Unsealed. They're also available online.
Uh here I deal extensively and carefully
with the issue of whether the
personation of Christ will be before or
after the close of probation. I want to
share just a few thoughts from these
study notes. There are many many many
pages. I'm only going to give the
highlights. Uh first of all, um in the
Bible in Matthew chapter 24 and verse
21, uh we speak we hear about the great
tribulation. If you would read that
text.
>> Yes, pastor. Matthew 24 verse 25.
>> Verse 20 21.
>> 21 rather. Okay. Thank you.
For then there will be great
tribulation,
such as has not been since the beginning
of the world until this time. No, nor
ever shall be.
>> Okay. So, this is the worst time of
trouble. There's not going to be a worse
one after this.
>> Exactly.
>> And there never was a worse one before
that.
>> That's right.
>> So, this is clearly the final time of
trouble after the close of probation.
>> Correct.
>> Uh Ellen White has an entire chapter on
this. Uh so um then in the following
verses verse 23 and 24 we have the
counterfeiting of Christ's second
coming.
>> Correct? It says there then if anyone
says to you look here is the Christ or
there do not believe it for false Christ
and false prophets will rise and show
great signs and wonders to deceive if
possible the very elect.
>> Okay. So it says very clearly here that
this takes place after the close of
probation in the sequence that we find
in Matthew chapter 24.
>> Um in harmony with this Ellen White
places the personation of Christ second
coming by Satan in the chapter on the
time of trouble. Mhm.
>> So both the Bible presents it saying
that you have great tribulation and then
you have uh Satan appearing. If they say
he's here, don't go out. If they say
he's there, you know, don't don't go. Uh
Ellen White places it within the context
of the great time of trouble and the
Bible places in in the context of the
great tribulation. Mhm.
>> So clearly in the sequence it's after
the close of probation. Now another
important thing is that you have the use
of the word tote uh in Matthew chapter
>> uh and many other places. It's used over
hundred times in the gospel of Matthew
where that word tote the word then in
English
>> always refers to an event that takes
place after another event.
>> Correct? So when it says then if they
say to you he's in the wilderness this
is after the great tribulation
>> because it's following a sequence
>> and without exception in Matthew over
100 times it always refers to an event
after another event. So in other words
you have the great tribulation and then
after the great tribulation you have uh
the one who comes and says Christ he's
Christ don't go out. Mhm.
>> So clearly it's during the great
tribulation. Uh now another important
point is that the target because some
people say you know why in the world
would Satan try to counterfeit the
second coming if uh the world is already
deceived.
>> What what would be the use?
>> Well, first of all, Ellen White says
Satan doesn't know. Uh he suspects that
God's people have been sealed.
>> Yeah.
>> But he doesn't know for sure. She says
that in the chapter of the time of
trouble. Uh furthermore, um when when
you look at Matthew chapter 24, the
focus of Satan's deceptions are not the
world.
>> He shall deceive, if possible, the very
elect. This is Satan last resort. You
see, he's got the whole world on his
side before probation closes. Probation
closes and the entire world is on his
side.
>> Yeah. But then probation closes and
there's still a small group that says we
don't go along.
>> So Satan is going to target them.
>> Yeah.
>> Because he says, "Hey, uh, you know,
I've gotten everybody on my side." Uh,
but this group insists on keeping the
Sabbath. So his target is the elect.
>> His target is not the world to to unite
the world uh, you know, in deception.
That's not his purpose. His purpose is
to get that small group who are still
consist contesting his authority. Uh now
Ellen White has a very interesting
comment about this and uh I'm going to
read just uh from here. Um
page in this study notes it's page 105
and 106. 105 and 106.
And um here uh she is going to uh I'm
going to uh present all of the
statements about this deception that
Satan is going to bring.
>> Mhm.
>> She says one more last desperate effort
to overcome the faithful. To overcome
who?
>> The faithful.
>> The faithful. She says it's Satan's last
device. It is one more effort. It is
Satan's last device. It is Satan's last
act. It is his last strategy. It is his
crowning act. It is about uh it is the
about to close last chance of subverting
these souls. The faithful cry day and
night for the deliverance. Um and Elwood
even gives us the moment when Satan is
going to personify the second coming of
Christ.
>> And that is she says when God's people
are praying. See if I can find this uh
statement. Um I have so many so many
places here. Um but but anyway, she says
that God's people are crying out day and
night.
>> Yes.
>> For their deliverance.
Every time that Ellen White uses that
expression unceasing cry or crying out
day and night, she's referring to God's
people crying out at the end of the time
of trouble when the death decree is
about to be executed.
>> It always is after the close of
probation.
>> And so it's interesting. She says that
God's people are raising their unceasing
cries for Jesus to deliver them. And
Ellen White says at that moment,
>> Satan comes.
>> Satan will come and say, "I have come to
answer your prayers." He comes
personifying Christ. He says, "I have
come to answer your prayers." And Ellen
White calls this the almost
overmastering delusion. But she says,
"The elect will not be deceived
>> because Satan is walking on the earth."
And we know Jesus isn't going to touch
the earth. And secondly, he's telling
everybody they're supposed to keep
Sunday. Uh and he the per his purpose is
to try and force God's people to keep
Sunday because they are the only ones
that remain. Uh so I would suggest that
uh that the person who asked this
question get these study notes.
>> Amen.
>> Um and there's much much more here.
There are pages and pages of material.
Behold, I send you Elijah. Pastor, thank
you. Wow. It is very interesting that
when we understand this clearly, we
actually see the interest of Satan to
deceive not the ones that are already
deceived, but to deceive those that are
elected as you mentioned. And also
because his whole existence depends on
whether or not these individuals remain
faithful to the Lord. And I think that
Satan, you know, he has tried in the
past and he might think at that moment,
you know, if I almost got John the
Baptist to, you know, reject Jesus or to
question Christ. If I almost got, you
know, uh Moses to to be uh unable to
enter the promised land by by you know
uh forgetting and striking the rogue
twice. Maybe I can get these
individuals, they are so pressed, they
are having, you know, through
tribulation. I can get them to see me as
the answer and help them or make them
deceive and receive this this display of
my power as an evidence to their prayer.
So I can see very clearly that this is
again an attempt of the enemy to destroy
the faith of the faithful to destroy the
faith in the word of God and to go by
sight and to in a way he's probably
thinking I can get them to break the law
of God and that way I will have triumph.
>> And she has a statement where she says
the devil has the world on his side. I'm
paraphrasing. Yeah.
>> And if he could overcome the faithful
his triumph would be complete. Exactly.
>> Because there would not be anyone that
that would uh that would be on Christ's
side.
>> And this is why he's so desperate to do
this this deception and to do this uh
you know personification of Jesus. Uh we
have to remain faithful to the word of
God and to know what we believe.
>> Amen. Well, our time has run out today.
Uh we didn't answer a lot of questions,
but this is an important one that comes
up all the time here at Secrets
Unsealed. And I always recommend these
study notes. Amen. because there's a
huge amount of material in there that
proves that this takes place after the
close of probation. We want to thank you
for your prayers. We covet your prayers.
We also want to thank you for your
financial support which makes it
possible to continue producing these
programs. Thank you so much for being
with us. God bless you and we hope to
see you on our next program.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]